there's another vector operation which
we call the vector product and sometimes
this operation is called the cross
product and this is taking two vectors a
the operation cross B and this will give
a new vector C and now we want to define
that new vector C so let's draw a
3-dimensional picture where we have a
plane and on this plane we have two
vectors a and B and those vectors are
forming an angle theta between them now
a plane defines two unit normals I'll
draw one up which I'm going to call n
hat right hand rule and the reason for
that right hand rule is if we take a
cross B then our right hand thumb is
pointing in the perpendicular direction
to the plane now I could have chosen a
unit vector down and had left hand rule
and this would correspond to taking my
left hand and having a cross B pointing
down so the way we're going to define
our cross product is with the right hand
rule and so we define it like this that
the vector C has magnitude the magnitude
of a times sine of theta the magnitude
of B and its direction is given by the
right hand rule now one of the reasons
for this definition is let's draw a
vector a and a vector b
when you have two vectors they define a
magnitude in the following way that we
can think about any two vectors define
an area of a parallelogram and we can
define that area as follows let's drop a
perpendicular and let's call this B perp
then the area which is a positive
quantity is given by and by the way our
angle theta here will be always positive
so we're gonna make it zero theta pi and
that way sine of theta is always a
positive quantity the area is the height
so that's be perp times the base which
is the magnitude today and so we can
write that as a and B the magnitude of B
perp is B sine theta so this quantity B
sine theta is precisely what's occurring
there so the magnitude of C is equal to
the area formed by the vectors a and B
and we have a choice of which way we
want to pick C to point and that's where
we're as a convention we're choosing the
right hand rule now again there's a
symmetry here in that I can also define
the area of that triangle in the
following way let's write this the theta
instead of taking how much of B is
perpendicular to the direction of a
let's drop a perpendicular this way and
write that as a perp and then the same
area can be expressed as the magnitude
of well will express it as a perp times
B
and a perp is the magnitude of a sine
theta times the magnitude of B and
that's our same definition as before and
so you see a sine theta is appearing
over here so in either choice our vector
operation says take any two vectors any
two vectors forms a parallelogram the
area that parallelogram is the magnitude
of the vector product and the direction
of this new vector C is given by the
right hand rule with respect to that
parallelogram in that sense